ميدانيا تتواصل المعارك هو عمليات القصف
المتبادل على طول الجبهه الاوكرانيه
وتزامنت معدويه سفارات الانذار في عدد من
المدن الاوكرانيه تحسبا لذرات جويه روسيه
وبينما اعلن الجانب الاوكرانيا ان القوات
الروسيه جداد قصفها لمقاطعات خرسون
وزبروجيو وميكولايب وان الجيش الاوكرانيه
في المقابل وجه ضربات للقوات الروسيه
وامسك بخطوط القتال لاسيما في المناطق
الريفيه
ركز الجانب الروسيه على نتائج الخسائر
المدنيه التي تم تسجيلها للرئ قصف
اوكرانيا على المناطق التي يسيطر عليها في
لوغانستان
صواريخ من طرازيل مارس الامريكيه
في خير صور نقابه الاداره العسكريه ان
المدينه تتعرضت للقصف المدفعيه وقذائف
الهاون نحو احدى و70 مره الليله الماضيه
قتل فيها 13 مدريا واصيب العشرات
من جانبها الحكوميه الاوكرانيه بمقتل
ثلاثه من افراد اجهزه الطوارئ اثناء ازاله
الغامض في منطقه